city light southern stars no such things
gone
too far
[Music]
i was born with my feet in motion grab
your tissues folks
because blake shelton and gwen stefani
just dropped the music video for their
new track
happy anywhere and it's the cutest thing
you'll see
all day on thursday the couple gave fans
an
inside look at their life together using
a ton
of super sweet home videos to accompany
the love song
you're the only thing that i'm chained
to i could be happy
anywhere
[Applause]
with you yeah like i said
it's the freaking cutest
yeah the beauty of the northern lights
in a press release blake opened up about
the sweet sentiment behind the track
we've all been in quarantine and
lockdown and hopefully we've been doing
that with somebody that we really love
and enjoy being around
that's what happened with gwen and me
this summer and this entire year
honestly that's we ended up making the
video
here and that was a blast and get this
blake chatted with the today show friday
and revealed that the video was actually
shot by gwen's brother
todd stefani while he was quarantined
with a couple in oklahoma
we were putting out this single and and
uh and so we were like
hey todd you know how to run a video
camera will you make a video
for us for for our new single and so
gwen's brother todd
uh figured out how to run this camera
and now we've got a
video for the new song and things just
kind of you know fell into place
[Music]
during a live stream on thursday gwen
said the video tells the totality of her
in the country singer's relationship
of course new music isn't the only thing
the singer has going on
i always love being here it's always
inspiring
the 50 year old is officially returning
as a coach on season 19
of the voice back in june a source told
et
she's over the moon about it blake saved
my life
everybody knows that like we are just
having the time of our lives and we
never expected that this late in our
lives so
we're just trying to save her every
every moment together and while gwen and
her fellow voice coach have been
quarantined together at his ranch amid
the coronavirus pandemic
our source says she's ready to get back
to work
quote as much as gwen loves her family
life at home
she needs that outlet she is a hard
worker and
so motivated she says it's in her blood
the singer will be joined on the show by
blake and returning coaches john legend
and
kelly clarkson anytime i can be around
blake is you know a blessing
as for her relationship status with her
longtime beau
a source previously told et she's in no
hurry to rush down the aisle
adding that she's put any wedding plans
on the back burner
gwen and blake trust and love each other
and have truly built
a wonderful family together so right now
she feels like she doesn't need to rock
the boat
i love being with him